-Finally, guys, you ever see
a photo in the news
and think that headline
should be better?
Well, we're gonna
take care of that right now.
It's time for
"News & Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ News & Improved ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
For example,
check out this first photo here.
The original headline was...
That headline
can definitely be improved
'cause if you only looked
at the photo,
the headline
could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Oi, Mum. Hello."
See how this works?
So, up next,
this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
"Hi! Wow, you look great."
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Yeah. Oh, yeah.
I'll text you the photo now."
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next headline was...
[ Laughter ]
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mouthing words ]
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
Eating it.
-Wow.
-Wow. Sad.
This next headline was...
[ Laughs ]
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
And finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That's all we have
for "News & Improved."
What a great show!